[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 para seguir toda la acción
de la copa américa y la eurocopa estos
son nuestros titulares la euro 2020 de
entrada en su etapa final con los
octavos de final varios de los favoritos
coincidieron en la parte alta del cuadro
que promete choques es de gran nivel
analizamos el camino hacia la final en
wembley
primer examen para la nueva italia la
azzurra enfrenta a austria en los
octavos de final de la eurocopa los de
roberto mancini exponen su invicto de 30
partidos ante un rival que juega a esta
instancia por primera vez
a falta de una fecha para el final de la
fase de grupos en la copa américa
colombia y chile ya piensan en los
cuartos de final el respiro les da
tiempo para reacomodar las piezas atrás
una ronda inicial irregular son
candidatos al título
como cada día le damos la bienvenida a
nuestra analista sala castro directora
del diario bass colombia sara bienvenida
hola federico un gusto estar con ustedes
y quisiera aprovechar unos segundos para
rendir homenaje hay un mario ramírez tal
vez uno de los jugadores más talentosos
que ha dado el fútbol colombiano uno de
esos cracks de barrio de cualquier
ciudad de cualquier país que ha
inspirado una generación completa y que
además hoy nos recuerda las víctimas de
esta pandemia y nuestro saludo para sus
familiares amigos y allegados por esta
triste noticia pero comenzamos con la
eurocopa tras dos días sin actividad que
iniciada su recta final con los octavos
y dos encuentros que ya vamos a repasar
pero primero vamos a ver cómo está el
cuadro con los 16 mejores del torneo en
la parte alta o parte izquierda del
cuadro quedaron ubicados buena parte de
los favoritos bélgica portugal es el
plato fuerte y encontramos a italia
francia croacia y españa en la otra
mitad inglaterra-alemania es un choque
con muchísima historia y el que se lleva
todas las miradas países bajos es otro
de los pesos pesados y puede haber lugar
para alguna sorpresa sala comencemos con
la parte más cargada del cuadro de la
izquierda algunos de los grandes favor
se vislumbra en un camino espinoso hacia
wembley quien puede prevalecer realmente
es muy complicado hablar de favoritos
porque casi que cinco equipos que han
sido candidatos a llevarse esta eurocopa
están en este lado del cuadro a ver
vamos a ponerlo por nombres estamos
hablando de bélgica de lukaku y de
bruijn de portugal de cristiano ronaldo
y de bernardo silva de italia de mancini
porque ese sí que es un colectivo de
austria de álava de francia de embate de
benzema y de pogba por ejemplo croacia
pues con modric que ha demostrado que
tiene fútbol para seguir escribiendo sus
leyendas y españa- que sigue siendo una
duda pero que con busquets y ese último
funcionamiento pues promete mucho en
esta copa entonces es muy difícil creo
que hay incluso predecir una semifinal y
casi que es imposible es un cuadro muy
competido y que casi que si bien hay
grandes favoritos como italia todos
pueden llegar a esa final después por el
otro lado el ganador del choque entre
inglaterra y alemania se perfila como
gran favorito en la otra parte de la
llave está países bajos
puede haber aquí algunas sorpresas se
pueden imponer más en la historia en
este caso pues estamos viendo un
dinamarca que en este momento también le
está ganando a gales
digamos con un potencial ofensivo muy
fuerte y tendría que enfrentarse
potencialmente a países bajos que ya lo
hemos dicho ha llegado cuestionado juega
bien pero no alcanza a ser un equipo
arrollador hasta este momento hay que
ver ahí que pesa más si la jerarquía o
ese trabajo de equipo y es que en 90
minutos al final lo que pasa es que los
entrenadores apuestan por una estrategia
una estrategia de cómo lograr esa
clasificación más allá de la idea de
juego y los equipos grandes tienen que
sostener la idea mientras los otros
pueden jugar más o menos hacer partidos
que los lleven a la siguiente fase te
pido un parrafito para ese choque de
muchísima historia que es
inglaterra-alemania bueno que decir de
inglaterra ya alemania lo primero es que
esta es una de las grandes generaciones
históricas de inglaterra y que por eso
se le pide tanto a santino que funcione
tal como representan todas las figuras
que tiene y luego alemania que viene en
un proceso de reconstrucción ya llegando
a los últimos momentos
de este periodo con el logo y que además
necesita también encontrar esas fichas
nuevas ellos desde hace tiempo digamos
que generaron un fútbol en el que se
apropian de muchas identidades antes se
decía que un fútbol directo un fútbol
muy ágil y luego incorporaron la técnica
entonces es un choque muy muy
interesante e italia inglaterra mostrado
mucha alegría para atacar pero también
deja muchos espacios entonces creo que
es un partidazo de esos que vale la pena
vivir y sobre todo luego que estemos
analizando al detalle cómo fue ese duelo
táctico y sobre todo las actuaciones
individuales que se comienzan a develar
mejor dicho desde este sábado con dos de
los encuentros de octavos en estos
momentos en dinamarca le está ganando 2
a 0 a galés con dos goles de casper
dolber mientras que más tarde chocan
italia y austria nos quedamos con este
duelo de contrastes pero también de
mucha historia este partido tuvo sus
primeros capítulos en 1912 incluso se
enfrentaron en los juegos olímpicos de
ese año la azzurra lidera el historial
con 17 victorias frente al as
que tiene su rival y registran 8 empates
en total italia acumulada 13 partidos
sin perder contra austria con 10
victorias y 3 empates además ganó los
cuatro duelos que jugaron en copas del
mundo italia también llegó a octavos de
final con puntaje ideal y son a 30
cotejos sin derrota mientras que para
los de francófona es su primera
experiencia en octavos de la euro
escuchamos a los entrenadores de cara al
encuentro
la de tu prima una última escuadra
austria es un excelente equipo tiene
algunos jugadores técnicos muy
habilidosos físicamente en la escuadra
son un equipo agresivo y no es fácil
enfrentarse a ellos y empezar también
pueden sacarte de tu juego porque
presionan muy bien vean que a falta de
ver que áreas como preserven
italia ha sido convincente en la
eurocopa juegan muy muy bien en ataque
tienen un buen juego posicional pero
también son peligrosos en la transición
para nosotros significa que no debemos
permitirnos ningún error especialmente
la construcción del juego
tenes ventures field para los dos
entrenadores parecen tener muy claro
cómo juegan su rival para la italia de
mancini que viene muy firme esta puede
ser una de sus primeras pruebas de fuego
claro a ver esta está italia mancini ha
emocionado y hemos hablado mucho de ella
porque la principal función o dificultad
que tiene un técnico es convencer a sus
jugadores convencerlos de una idea y es
que italia venía de uno de los peores
pesadillas de la historia de su fútbol
la no clasificación al mundial de rusia
2018 y qué hace él lo primero es que
agarro una idea que bien podría ser
contra cultural porque se recuerda mucho
en estos días de esa frase de que elin y
de que guardiola daño a los a los
defensas italianos podría ser contra
cultural pero empieza a adaptarlo a unos
jugadores jóvenes más jugadores de
experiencia y sobre todo ha sido fiel a
eso que él quiere eso que él quiere a de
esta italia es un choque importante duro
él explicaba muy bien las
características que tiene austria es un
equipo que en la presión puede
complicarles esa construcción del juego
ofensivo pero sin duda creemos que como
bien este equipo un equipo muy bien
granado también en lo emocional en la
competencia sana por las posiciones
creemos que va a ser un partido en el
que italia va a poder seguir demostrando
lo que ha construido tiene con qué
austria para dar la sorpresa bueno lo
digo claramente mancini hay jugadores
interesantes importantes que hacen daño
el tenemos poder sostener el ritmo los
90 minutos ahí está italia que sabe
hacer muy bien muchas cosas
ojalá creo que es un partido interesante
creo que en general todos los cruces se
van a tener una buena calidad es decir
no creo que nadie le vaya a pasar por
encima al otro pero depende también de
los inicios si llega a meterse austria
atrás digamos en una zona más defensiva
ya vimos a italia como rompió un poco la
barrera que intentó poner turquía en la
primera fase entonces creo que el equipo
de mancini puede tener varias soluciones
para el tipo de juego que proponga usted
dejamos por un momento de la eurocopa y
pasamos a la copa américa que se toma el
último respiro antes del cierre de la
fase de grupos que se completará entre
domingo y lunes este domingo
precisamente será la definición del
grupo b
brasilia primero y clasificado
enfrentará a ecuador que necesita ganar
para no depender de nadie y en el otro
duelo pero jugará un mano a mano ante
venezuela-colombia queda libre a la
espera de saber si será tercera o cuarta
el lunes en se va a cerrar el grupo a
argentina buscará asegurarse el primer
lugar ante bolivia que ya está eliminada
y uruguay paraguay dirimirán quién se
queda con el segundo puesto de ese
resultado depende que chile sea tercero
o cuarto
frank fabra el lateral de la selección
colombia se mostró confiado para la
recta fin
el torneo
no creo que más allá de cuál sea rival
tenemos que estar preparados
así como estuvimos preparado contra
brasil como tuvimos preparados los
partidos anteriores creo que la cabeza
de nosotros tiene que estar puesta un
solo objetivo que es poder ir a hasta la
final y poder ganarla la copa américa
así que
sara colombia y chile tuvieron un andar
irregular en una fase de grupo que
también fue muy apretada por los tiempos
de descanso entre uno y otro que les
puede dar a reinaldo rueda y al
entrenador martín lasarte este tiempo
más largo de descanso para prepararse
para la próxima instancia días de
trabajo y de recuperación que no
tuvieron antes venían de unas jornadas
muy llenas de partidos después de la
eliminatoria entrando casi que en
competencia de una en copa américa y eso
es difícil yo creo que siempre hemos
cuestionado los niveles reales de estas
elecciones en la copa américa porque no
hemos visto como un rendimiento parejo
un rendimiento como evolutivo hacia
arriba es complicado por eso porque hay
jugadores con desgaste y estas
elecciones tienen a más fichas muy
importantes que cuando no están o no
funcionan bien decae el rendimiento
colectivo estos días van a ser muy
importantes y chile- para mí es sigue
siendo candidata porque tiene si esos
jugadores de experiencia que ya lograron
superar fases como estas que en las que
pesan no sólo el fútbol sino la presión
la mente y sobre todo esa necesidad de
clasificarse para
una final pues ya veremos entonces cómo
les va a chile ya colombia en la parte
final del torneo ahora en diarios de
copas repasamos otras novedades
vinculadas a estos dos torneos son la
copa américa y la eurocopa
empezamos con chiles que precisamente
regreso a santiago en la noche del
viernes para encarar su preparación para
los cuartos de final
en estos días el entrenador martín
lasarte intentará recuperar lesionados y
descomprimir el agotamiento de sus
jugadores según las propias palabras del
técnico uruguayo la roja espera a
conocer su rival si termina cuarta en el
grupo a jugará con brasil
[Música]
a una semana de recibir un partido de
los cuartos de final san petersburgo
registró 107 muertos vinculados al
hobbit 19 en las últimas 24 horas un
récord desde el inicio de la pandemia
las autoridades negaron que el repunte
esté ligado al fútbol y la apuntaron al
incumplimiento de las normas sanitarias
por parte de los ciudadanos
thomas müller se recuperó de sus
problemas de rodilla y está disponible
para el duelo de alemania contra
inglaterra del próximo martes en wembley
el delantero indicó que no sufre dolor y
que tiene experiencia para gestionar su
lesión posiblemente ingrese por leroy
sane de floja tarea ante hungría
hasta aquí diario de copas muchas
gracias ahora por acompañarnos
nuevamente y a todos ustedes por estar
del otro lado siga con más en france 24
y france 24 puntocom
i